[Music]
how's it going rest my name
let's loot this jet and steal it Paris's
my collar for school all that makes me
delighted anyway last episode we frickin
got our no wait what did we get back
yeah we got a notebook back but are you
gonna get a freaking phone back so I
have a bunch of phone numbers but
knowing a call usually it's the opposite
for me it's usually a bunch of phones
but no one quite none okay just whatever
so um yeah we're just gonna stroll our
way through these hallways like we
always do and it's you're gonna love it
cuz cuz there's piano this time
ah she's obviously failing there we go
play correct woman I'll slap your
fingers oh he's doing his focus uh-huh -
ah oh it's the fatty oh oh oh oh she's
gonna oh oh I'm gonna aw she's playing
with her kiddies how's it not not
playing with them playing the piano way
whatever it should be okay if I crouch
and move closer
that's my piano on top it's about
everything you can't even play your sock
you gotta stop just cuz they are learn
to [ __ ] play noob holy [ __ ]
whoops I didn't count all snap oh no oh
no they're gonna rape me now aren't they
how's that they raped me dinner oh don't
rape me please
sensitive but I don't like getting right
hey drought alright let's see if we're
gonna accompany her probably should oh
snap
she's gonna rape me that's what we know
stop disconnecting stupid Wiimote I will
kill you
alright crouched like about from Asti
hahaha focus okay super serious
super duper uber focus place your sock
why can I move Holly [ __ ] what I'm
saying I was crouching what do you want
from me woman Holly [ __ ]
[Music]
don't you dad alright we'll try a new
tech player stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're fat - I am no idea what to
do at this point I am so [ __ ] why did
you look up what did you do now this is
really difficult
yeah don't you sit that and be like oh
these are stupid
I would do much better job than him no
you wouldn't
oh you wouldn't you don't you're mean
I'm a [ __ ] I'll dare you I'm right
here
I feel like a pervert sucking up on
young girls in school outfits all right
why do you keep going up your stupid
[ __ ] he goes up I don't do it [ __ ] I
sweat out
[Music]
all right super serious focus face
where's the [ __ ] phone
[Music]
where's the [ __ ] phone today the
piano woman there you go
[ __ ] me
[Music]
okay let's do it now you little [ __ ]
give me my dog oh [ __ ] that didn't work
ha did you see the face on a fatty like
all right the phone is on the table
this is do this you can't see me [ __ ]
retards alright now we'll go to death
[ __ ]
well that didn't exactly go as planned
[Music]
you can see [ __ ] alright let's just take
it
alright let's get the [ __ ] outta let's
get the [ __ ] outta it one more time than
that I'm so dad I'm so dad I'm so dad
I'm frickin under overkill okay
hey how's everyone doing oh no dead ends
all right that's good it happens every
Tuesday all right don't help me please
I'm very sensitive to humping all right
[ __ ] me took about 30 minutes to get
past this [ __ ] part I'm I don't even
know anymore thank you very much all
right fine
I'm all this mechanic piss now seriously
I'm sick of this [ __ ] caught it all
right how do I turn on my phone Tevan
have my flashlight do i well I have my
cellphone now that's something to be
happy about and I have my fresh thyme
maca thank you very much oh no I can't
see it in the darkness that's a shame
that's a bloody damn shame everything is
just by the other stupid [ __ ] cell
phone nine nine eight eight nine four
five one six better work yes thank
heavens Lord Almighty I'm so glad I'm
getting out of this [ __ ] school I'm
so sick of this
really and then this teleport me already
I get the point
it's ringing holy [ __ ]
I want to kill someone oh yay we're back
here with the creepy [ __ ] Dalton
whatever lovely hey doll how you doing
alright that's a lot of cubic hair for a
closet someone all right dolls lovely
all right
yeah the cost of this aren't you alright
let's go let it stop someone's making
love alright let's leave them alone with
the pubic hair and stuff I can't go
inside probably if only had something to
cut the hair with Oh teleport there and
then we'll oh man I'm such a genius I
know why I had that look like a creepy
segment for that but alright let's just
teleport like we always do to the
beautiful nine nine seven six eight four
seven seven one all right lights go and
take the steel this is sir I hope she's
not gonna have a problem with it it was
pretty creepy she - I don't like her
very much no good no me gusta plenty
okay and that's just teleport already do
it oh alright
hey dolls attention [ __ ] that's what
you are alright mean damages Amy just
get that sister and I'll be on my way
alright so you know it's not here I'm
Shirley what oh snap
literally snap
[Music]
alright girl I don't give me a haircut I
like my hat place
oh [ __ ] she's coming out of that Josh do
you really want to give me a haircut
don't you well I'm not gonna give you to
you alright huh oh don't give me high
god what did I say two seconds ago
holy [ __ ] oh no all right I get it [ __ ]
all right No oh no should I let her in I
mean it's polite holy [ __ ] I'm glad I
saved let's not open that door that's a
forbidden door right there holy [ __ ] she
just tear that [ __ ] open
all right we're safe here lucky save kid
can do something no I'm not gonna fall
for that trick again
stupid girl I don't fall for tricks all
right maybe I should save kitty cat
waking up
there's no time for sleeping septic you
can't win war and war I don't know what
to do she just went to kill me
all right I'll just have a red ball and
she likes all right oh no I don't have
red balls [ __ ] me okay let's turn on the
lights maybe she'll be all that calm no
I can't do anything about it
mrs. hairdresser if you play nice and
maybe let you cut a couple inches maybe
all right all right we're good it's a
deal it's a [ __ ] deal don't just
don't stab me in my balls with this is
really hard it's not a joke I know why I
don't even joke about our god damage
still has a suitor barrel oh it's not a
barrel
all right that color products are lined
up just like my opinion okay room trout
lovely
mister plaid what are you doing don't
try to attack me we're on the same team
mr. plan I'm deeply disappointed at you
it's okay for this time mr. Pat but next
time I've seriously [ __ ] you up what is
this she just left it in the door I
obtained scizor scizor my sister
schnitzel fritter all right let's make
some lesbian laughs I'm just kidding
anyway kind of ended here bro hope you
enjoy like impaired if you did subscribe
to come abroad today and I'll see you
next episode
[Music]
what nah